We have to talk about this hello world.
It's Saroj and Chinoiserie Chinese state
government run news organization just
for build the first AI news anchor.
They train the model on video
data from real news anchors,
so it was able to learn relevant
features like speech patterns and facial
movements, but they didn't reveal
the type of model they used,
so I'm going to take an educated guess.
It's very likely that they use what's
called a generative adversarial network
Orgam to do this and have proven to be
able to generate all sorts of data that
looks very real, but it's
fake. The process is simple.
One neural network called the generator
is fed random data as input and
transforms it through a series of matrix
math operations and to an output image.
Another neural network called
the discriminator is fed
an image from the actual
training data,
which in our case would be a single video
frame and through a series of again,
matrix operations outputs
a simple binary value,
classifying it as real or fake.
We also feed the discriminator,
the output of the generator and since
it's so different from the real data,
it will classify it as fake.
We can measure just how different it is
from the real image and by using this
error value we can change the numerical
values ever so slightly in both networks
such that in the next iteration the
generator will produce a more realistic
looking image. Since videos are
just a series of image frames,
we can use a fully trained generator to
eventually output very realistic video
data,
combine it with a text to speech system
and this anchor is capable of working 24
hours a day without needing any breaks,
which greatly reduces the cost of news
production and improves efficiency.
She also claims that it's capable of
learning from live broadcast videos.
China has accomplished an
incredible feat in just 30 years.
It's transformed itself from one of the
world's poorest countries to its second
largest economy in China.
The relationship between state and society
is profoundly different from that in
the west. And so our, its
various traditions of governance,
some of which date back
to 5,000 years ago,
their values reflect Confucianist
philosophy, meaning plurality,
pragmatism and collectivism,
not individualism.
All of this has shaped its government
and it's impossible to talk about China's
rise to AI power without talking
about its most powerful figure.
Xi Jinping Xi is the general secretary
of the Chinese Communist Party.
He's at the core of a seven member
Standing Committee of the politburo and
together they formed the inner most
circle of China's governance structures.
All Chinese institutions
including the government court,
military and crucially tech
companies report to this party.
She's 40 year long,
uh,
sent to the presidency involved 16
major promotions through county,
city and province levels and then numerous
other institutions with reviews at
every single state to assess
his leadership abilities.
And despite numerous human rights abuses,
endless press,
censorship and environmental damage,
this authoritarian structure has driven
China to become the second largest
economy in the world.
She has near absolute power.
The man is even enshrined
in the constitution itself.
This is important because a quick look
at his bookshelf during his annual New
Year's Day greeting shows that
he has copies of Pedro Domingos,
the Master Algorithm, and Brett kings
augmented life in the smart lane,
both of which discuss AI
technologies in detail.
I've read the master algorithm.
That book is technical.
It covers concepts like Bayesian
inference and support vector machines.
She understands the transformational
power of AI at a technical level,
arguably more than many
other world leaders,
and this has manifested itself in China's
ambitious AI plan by 2020 it envisions
that China's progress in AI should keep
pace with the world advanced level.
While it's AI industry becomes an
important economic growth point by 2025 at
once,
you have achieved a major breakthrough
in AI to reach a leading level with AI
becoming the primary driver for China's
industrial advances and economic
transformation.
And by 2030 in wants to become the
world's Premiere Ai Innovation Center,
a $1 trillion AI industry.
When it comes to the implementation of Ai.
China has one clear advantage over
other countries in that it's the most
populated country in the world,
which means more data.
Ai Algorithm needs lots of data
to learn from. The more data,
the better the result. What matters
in implementation of Ai is speed,
product quality, data,
government support and execution,
all of which China is excelling at.
But the U S and Canada have
an edge in AI research.
The top researchers in the
world still live there.
If the climate for researchers in China
becomes drastically better though,
don't expect them to
keep their allegiances.
The Chinese AI startup
environment is very gladiator.
Like think survival of the
fittest. Fail fast, fail early,
fail often working very long hours is
the norm as that's what's necessary to
succeed.
Take Uber for example.
Uber is a business that was
invented in the u s in matches,
drivers and riders together with cars
being the mode of transportation in China.
However, as startups started
trying to emulate Uber,
they try out every possible iteration,
shared mopeds, shared bikes,
shared concrete mixers, shared mobile
phone chargers. Many of them died,
but a few like mobike rose up to become
Unicorn companies reaching 20 million
rides per day and being sold for
two point $7 billion in three years.
This rapid prototyping and tweaking
approach is uniquely Chinese.
Another example is food delivery.
Postmates is a successful US
company that offers food delivery,
but it would never work in
China. Why? Because may Twan,
it's Chinese equivalent,
is able to deliver food to any location
within 30 minutes and under 70 cents are
faster and cheaper that
Postmates ever could.
That's because the founder learned that
people wanted to eat, take out food,
but it had to be delivered within 30
minutes and that the costs should be
brought down to 70 cents per delivery
in order to profitably offer free
delivery.
May Twan worked on this problem for years.
Eventually they hired 600 k people on
mopeds inventing an AI algorithm to find
writers willing to work during meal
hours and modifying the vehicle to be low
cost using battery power.
It took them billions of dollars of
losses and many years of iteration before
they got there,
but they did it.
Chinese companies are ruthless stealing
best practices from each other,
copying what works.
So what may Twan did was
build an indestructible moat.
It would require far too much time,
capital and effort for any copycat to
build the infrastructure that they did and
that's how they won.
Because of this,
it's valued at 60 billion US dollars
to compare in the u s Groupon,
Yelp and open table are collectively
worth less than one 10th of that.
Chinese apps are often more feature
rich and efficient than their American
counterparts. We chat for example,
it's like whatsapp on steroids.
Not only can you message people, you
can book a taxi, get food deliveries,
pay your bills,
book train tickets all from one act.
This does bring up the
question of privacy.
Giant Chinese tech companies like Tencent
and Alibaba are gathering huge amounts
of data from their users.
Outcries on Chinese social media show
that citizens have been concerned that
their data was being mined illegitimately
by private companies and sold on the
black market.
In response to this.
China issued their first data protection
standard that lays out rules around
what is consent and the conditions upon
which companies can collect personal
data.
The way the government responds to
public outcry is not through a democratic
process.
Unlike his predecessor who allowed
people to voice their opinions to the
government directly through
democratic means like town halls.
She uses a combination of surveillance,
AI and big data to monitor people's
lives and behavior in minute detail.
Every day he gets a briefing on public
sentiment scrapped from the web on
various issues. She is also very
interested in autonomous weapons.
Just this month,
31 high school children were selected
for a four year program in AI weapons
systems out of more than five k candidates
think drones that decide who to kill,
how to kill them and do so more
efficiently than any human ever could.
This kind of technology put into the wrong
hands could quickly become weapons of
mass destruction,
but there is hope by Du has recently
become the first Chinese company to join a
u s led alliance on AI
called the partnership on Ai.
This effort to include China in the
global discussion on regulating AI is one
step in the right direction.
She also doesn't like being
compared to Winnie the Pooh,
so all references mentioning that phrase
are classified using neural network
technology and systematically deleted.
The state government holds a tight grip
on all social network data, all voices,
all media,
everything is controlled.
The amount of surveillance and
censorship in China is truly astounding.
Cameras are installed across
countless street corners in stores,
in offices using computer vision
technology powered by convolutional neural
networks to detect and
identify people's faces.
This helps the government track people
based on their social credit score and
modify it based on their behavior.
The social credit score system
is a centralized database
that gives each citizen
a number that defines their reputation.
The problem is that social
trust has eroded in China.
Everyone has an aunt or uncle who's
been swindled or scammed by someone,
and the reason for that is that the
Chinese government doesn't allow for third
party social institutions to exist outside
of the scope of government influence
and control.
It's a government created problem and
they provided a government created
solution,
the social credit score system,
so while many Chinese are wary of it,
they welcome it as a way to potentially
remedy the crisis of social trust,
financial records, criminal
records, online social network data.
Whether or not you buy alcohol,
all of it informs your credit score.
They've used it to ban people from
traveling on trains and the government can
even reduce your social score
if you disagree with its policy.
It also uses AI to predict crimes.
Police officer's regularly visit certain
homes to collect data on things like
how many people live in a household,
how many times they prey,
what books they have,
and these data streams are fed
into a public security system.
Their algorithm aggregates all the data
from these different sources and flags
who might become a threat to authorities.
We don't know what the
algorithm is exactly,
but it's likely a deep learning
classifier out putting a probability of
criminality. We can thus think
of the Internet in China,
like a real time privately run
digital intelligence service.
The great firewall has blocked countless
American services from reaching the
Chinese population. Despite the
government using AI to exploit people,
censor the population,
and create autonomous weapons.
It's also using AI to lift people out of
poverty and increase economic stability.
Surveys show that while the Chinese
majority generally like their style of
government,
there's also a strong demand in China for
Western values like freedom of speech,
government transparency,
and rule of law.
The best thing we can do is partner
with the Chinese across industries,
respect their unique society
and way of doing things,
and provide uncensorable applications
using blockchain technology that allow
them to connect with
the rest of the world.
Because as long as we all have a voice,
it makes it much harder to
violate basic human rights.
It's an exciting time for China
and the rest of the world.
Shisha please subscribe for more
programming videos and for now,
I've got to visit China sometime,
so thanks for watching.